The system would enrich the
prospect, it would research,
it goes to each prospect,
it does a complete research,
tells us why this person
may be relevant for us,
gives us the signals and
the outreach angles that we
can do.
Now the emails
are being generated by the
system based on the research
and based on what it
learned about your service
and it creates the emails.
And it could either be
when a user fills up
a form on your website
and then the voice agent
immediately calls him.
Thanks for calling
MeetingScheduled.
How can I help you
today?
MeetingScheduled builds digital
phone receptionists for
businesses, so your calls can
be answered automatically,
even after hours or when
your team is busy.
This is the Speed Dialer
app where you are able
to call, email,
WhatsApp, look at the company.
once I do the call
I'm able to see my
recent calls you
download them to see the
transcript of each one When
we click on one of
the leads we've spoken with,
we can hear the recordings.
We can see the transcript
directly here,